Sean Connery was the first, and for legions of fans, the best,...
...the ultimate British spy, James Bond.
Martini, shaken not stirred.
Did you have any idea it would grow to be what it has become?
No, no, nobody did.
Bond.
Connery almost wasn't Bond.
Creator Ian Fleming called him an overgrown stuntman.
The son of a truck driver in Scotland, he joined the navy at 16,...
...but his rugged good looks got him noticed,...
...first, in a Mr. Universe contest;...
...the tough Chicago cop in The Untouchables.
I thank you all sincerely.
The movie roles kept coming,...
Welcome to the Rock.
...so did the honors like People Magazine's Sexiest Man of the Year,...
...not the way Connery saw himself.
Presidents honored him.
The Queen knighted him.
After half a century on screen, Connery retired from acting for good.
I don't look back very much to be honest.
No matter the age, always Bond.
James Bond.